je viens vous pas plus d'internet
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 18 décembre
18e ouverture de ce calendrier de la
vente le jour à 6 heures du matin comme
d'habitude et je vous parle de quelque
chose de vous je trouvais ça intéressant
d'en parler dans la chaîne durant ce
calendrier mais bon je vous dis souvent
je continue à informer en temps que
mentalist va intéresser à tout ce qui se
fait tout ce qui sort mais c'est pas
très concret quand je vous dis ça et ben
voilà un exemple très concret je me suis
acheté c'était au mois de septembre tous
addict et après donc un bouquin sur les
addictions
là vous dites il est où le rapport avec
le mentalisme c'est vrai il est ou qui
est bien ces dernières années il ya eu
beaucoup d'avancées en fait dans le dans
l'approché dans le traitement des
addictions et aussi beaucoup d'avancées
dans les nouvelles addictions qui existe
et ce livre compile un petit peu tout ça
et va parler en trois thèmes des
addictions à des substances licites
comme le tabac ou l'alcool par exemple
des addictions à des substances
illicites comme la cocaïne l'héroïne et
les addictions à des choses sans
substances comme les jeux vidéo le sexe
les écrans etc dans le xterra jeu mais
aussi le sport tas d addicts aux sports
tout ça ce sont des addictions qu'on
oublie un petit peu et le livre va re
détaillé tout ça va faire une espèce de
mise à jour par rapport à tout ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui et va surtout et c'est
ça qui est intéressant mentalisme
parlait du processus du comportement
pourquoi ça arrive
comment ça arrive et après les solutions
qui existent pour essayer d'en sortir ou
les pistes de réflexion qui a en ce
moment sur les travaux en cours
parce que aujourd'hui il ya plein de
potentiel qui sont pas forcément
exploiter de travaux ou de prévention
donc soit pour s'en sortir soit pour
prévenir et ce que j'ai trouvé vraiment
passionnant dans le livre alors les
auteurs sont william lowenstein et
laurent karila lui est un médecin
dernier spécialisé en addictologie et
elle est une psychiatre spécialisé en
addictologie qui décrivent aussi tout le
processus de la diction et c'est ça qui
est passionnant
comment ça se fait qu'à un moment donné
on devient addict à quelque chose et est
ce que en plus on a vraiment conscience
de ça et quelle est notre comportement
qu'on est addict à quelque chose sans en
avoir conscience
et du coup quelles sont les interactions
ont peu à voir avec une personne comme
ça ce qui à ce stade là de la vidéo ne
vois pas le lien avec le mentalisme ce
sont des personnes qui vous en faite de
parties qui pensent que le mentaliste
est uniquement essayer de deviner ce à
quoi quelqu'un pense ou influencer à
choix
encore une fois ma définition du
mentalisme elle est beaucoup plus large
que ça allez on va dire dans la
compréhension des choses d'où mon kif
pour les énigmes par exemple et toutes
les vidéos je vous ai fait ce mois-ci ou
dans la compréhension de l'être humain
et ça ça en fait clairement partie ce
livre je vous en parle vraiment est ce
qu'il est vulgariser donc très abordable
et il prendre comme ça tous ces thèmes
point par point jeudi dans les
substances illicites
on a le cannabis la cocaïne l'héroïne la
mdm a les nouveaux produits sainté est
ce qu'on trouve trop facilement sur
internet dans l'hémicycle l'alcool le
tabac les médicaments dans l'est sans
substance sexe écran bin djaouad shing
jeu l'addiction alimentaire pouvoir qu'a
holisme les junkies 10sport acheteurs et
acheter en série les san addict parce
qu'on a aussi des addicts du soleil qui
vont faire beaucoup du v c'est
passionnant
voilà si vous êtes juste curieux de
nature et curieux d'un petit peu tout
est toujours intéressé par tous les
aspects du mentalisme je vous recommande
ce livre c'est édité chez flammarion
j'ai l'impression d'être bernard pivot
qui vient de présenter un nouveau livre
nike et la vidéo si ça vous a plu
n'oubliez pas de laisser un com si vous
avez des questions un petit peu plus
précise sur le livre j'y répondrai et
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner rendez
vous demain matin à 6h chat
[Musique]
bon
oh
je